>> Laura: IMAGINE THIS FLYING
ANYWHERE ELSE.
LAST NIGHT DON LEMON THOUGHT IT
WAS HILARIOUS WHEN GUESTS ON HIS
SHOW MARKED KANYE WEST'S
INTELLIGENCE AHEAD OF THE
RAPPERS MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THURSDAY,
TOMORROW.
AND IT WAS DONE IN THE MOST
OFFENSIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
WATCH.
>> KANYE WEST IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN THEY DON'T READ IT, AND WE
HAVE THIS NOW AND NOW
DONALD TRUMP WILL USE IT AND
PERVERTED AND HE WILL HAVE
SOMEONE THAT CAN STAND WITH HIM
AND TAKE PICTURES.
>> AND HE IS AN ATTENTION OR
LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
HE'S ALL OF A SUDDEN A MODEL
SPOKESPERSON, HE IS THE TOKEN OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE TAKING
KANYE WEST SERIOUSLY.
HE CLEARLY HAS ISSUES, HE'S
ALREADY BEEN HOSPITALIZED.
>> Laura: IS JOINING ME WITH
THE REACTION OWENS, AND IT
REALLY TURNS OUT THAT THEY
CANNOT ACCEPT ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH THEM WHO HAS ANY
AFFINITY FOR OR ANY AGREEMENT
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHO IS THE INTOLERANT ONE NOW,
CANDACE?
>> IF THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
INTOLERANT.
BUT MOST ESPECIALLY TO ADD TO
YOUR STATEMENT, MOST ESPECIALLY
BLACK PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS RELY ON OUR VOTE.
IF THEY SECURED 85% OF OUR VOTE,
THEY WOULD LOSE.
THEY WOULD ACHIEVE MORE THAN 85%
OF THE BLACK VOTE TO SUSTAIN
THEIR PARTY, AND WHAT THEY SAID
LAST NIGHT WAS NOT ONLY RACIST
BUT ABSOLUTELY DESPICABLE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
ALLOWED ON ANY NETWORK, LEAST OF
ALL HAVE A HOST OF LAUGHING AS
IF IT'S FUNNY.
>> Laura: THE ENTIRE PANEL
KIND OF WENT ON WITH THAT.
IMAGINE IF A CONSERVATIVE HOST
HAD A GUEST ON THAT SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND LEFT?
THERE WOULD BE CALLS FOR
BOYCOTTS.
I GOT IN TROUBLE WITH LeBRON
JAMES, I WAS JUST TEASING HIM,
AND HE SAID, YOU CAN'T SAY --
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T JOKE BUT
THEY CAN SAY THE MOST HORRIFIC
THINGS POSSIBLE AND, YOU ARE
SHUT DOWN.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN, THOUGH, FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
I THINK THEY ARE WORRIED, ARE
THEY NOT, CANDACE?
YOU'VE BROKEN THROUGH IN YOUR
OWN WAY IN POLITICS, YOU HAVE
KIND OF COME ONTO THE SCENE, AND
THERE ARE OTHERS COMING FORWARD
SAYING, THE DEMONIZATION OF
DONALD TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICANS, THE ECONOMY IS
DOING WELL -- OF THE MARKET IS
DOWN TODAY BUT THIS KIND OF
THING HAPPENS.
BUT THINGS ARE GOING WELL AND
PEOPLE SEEM REALLY ANGRY ALL THE
TIME AND IT KIND OF DOESN'T
COMPUTE AT SOME POINT.
>> THE ANGER IS MASKING THEIR
INSECURITY, THEY ARE TERRIFIED.
THEY WERE NOT PREDICTING THIS
AND THEY HAD NO IDEA THAT THERE
WAS ANY CHANCE THAT
CONSERVATIVES MIGHT COME AFTER
THE CULTURAL WAR.
THEY WON THE CULTURAL WORE A
LONG TIME AGO.
SO FOR KANYE WEST TO STAND UP
AND SAY I SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP,
THAT TERRIFIES THEM.
SO THEY WILL SAY WHATEVER THEY
CAN TO SMEAR HIM TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO OTHER BLACK PEOPLE WAKE
UP AND UNDERSTAND THAT IT HAS
BEEN THE LEFT THAT HAS HARMED
OUR COMMUNITY.
IT HAS BEEN DEMOCRAT POLICIES
THAT HAVE RENDERED OUR
COMMUNITIES INITIATE THAT THEY
ARE IN TODAY, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
CHICAGO, PHILADELPHIA, AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT HAVE RUN DOWN.
BLACK PEOPLE ARE HAVING A
MASSIVE AWAKENING AND KANYE WEST
IS ONE REASON WHY.
>> Laura: YOU'VE MET
KANYE WEST AND I GUESS YOU WILL
MEET HIM TOMORROW BEFORE HIS
LUNCH WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
STRIKE UP SOMETHING ABOUT
FRIENDSHIP.
WHAT IS IT WITH HIM AND TRUMP?
ARE THEY PALS OR IS THERE A PAST
TOWARDS CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
OR PRISON REFORM, OTHER WORK
THEY MIGHT DO TO GET KIDS OUT OF
GANGS?
WHAT'S A COLLABORATION THERE?
>> I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR
HIM, BUT I WILL TELL YOU MY
ASSESSMENT AFTER HAVING SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH HIM.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, CONNIE IS
EDUCATED ABOUT THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY AND THE HISTORY OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BEYOND THAT, KANYE WEST BELIEVES
IN UNITED BOTH SIDES AND GOING
FORWARD.
WE KNOW THE LEFT, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS SEPARATE
AND THEY WANT TO KEEP THE FEARS
OF RACISM AND FEARMONGERING
ALIVE.
KANYE WEST DOESN'T WANT THOSE
THINGS.
HE WANTS THE WORLD TO BE BETTER
THAN IT WAS YESTERDAY AND HE
SEES A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY IN
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE SEES
THAT OUR PRESIDENT IS COURAGEOUS
AND WILLING TO SAY THE THINGS
THAT WOULDN'T BE SAID.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT CERTAINLY
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WHILE
BARACK OBAMA WAS IN OFFICE.
>> Laura: I THINK THEY ARE